[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui le confinement ça a des effets
bénéfiques et donc ça va agir comme un
facilitateur
mais le principal problème c'est que
retour de la biodiversité égale
recolonisation pérenne du milieu urbain
par des espèces qui en ont disparu
depuis très longtemps
donc c'est un processus qui va pas se
jouer en quelques semaines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en plus
[Musique]
je
oh
le changement qu'on observe pour
l'instant ils sont surtout au niveau de
notre perception des oiseaux à la fois
parce que les gens passent beaucoup plus
de temps à faire de l'ornithologie
urbaine puisqu'ils sont confinés et
aussi parce qu'on entend beaucoup mieux
et donc on a une bien meilleure capacité
de détection des oiseaux par rapport à
d'habitude on sait que les oiseaux
adapte la fréquence ou la puissance les
plages horaires de leurs champs leurs
vocalisation pour éviter d'entrer en
compétition avec les bruits produits par
les agglomérations des avions la
circulation et donc on peut imaginer que
avec cette réduction du trafic routier
et aérien etc
on est un retour à progressif à des
normes qui ressemble plus à ce qu'on
trouve dans les campagnes
[Musique]